I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello everyone. Hey there.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。大家好。嘿，大家好。
How's it going? We're the office ladies. Hello, everyone. Hey there. How's it going? You know, it's going fantastic. Uh-huh. I'm ready for some trivia. I hope so because that's what we're talking about today. Season 8, episode 11, written by Steve Healy and directed by B.J. Novak.
最近怎么样？我们是办公室辣妈。大家好。嘿，大家好。最近怎么样？你知道，过得棒极了。嗯哼。我已经准备好迎接一些冷知识了。我希望如此，因为这就是我们今天要聊的内容。第八季第11集，由史蒂夫·希利编剧，B.J.诺瓦克执导。
How about a summary? You know, I love it. Andy recruits the gang to compete in a trivia night in hopes that their winnings will close the gap on their quarterly sales goal. Meanwhile, Dwight flies to Florida in pursuit of a management position. Mm-hmm.
来个剧情概要怎么样？你知道的，我喜欢。安迪召集大家去参加一个知识竞赛之夜，希望他们的奖金能缩小季度销售目标的差距。与此同时，德怀特飞往佛罗里达去争取一个管理职位。嗯哼。
Very bold move. I mean, Robert did invite him, but I think Robert invites people, I mean, much like Joe Bennett. Mm-hmm. Maybe sometimes invite you, but they don't really mean the invite. Yeah, it's like a soft invite. I think it's, what do you call it?
非常大胆的举动。我的意思是，罗伯特确实邀请了他，但我觉得罗伯特邀请人，我的意思是，很像乔·贝内特。嗯哼。也许有时会邀请你，但他们并不是真的想邀请。对，这就像是个委婉的邀请。我觉得这是，你叫它什么来着？
I don't even think it's a soft invite. It's a, I think it's a non invite invite. A hypothetical invite. Yes. Okay. Yeah. Why doesn't live in hypotheticals? No, no.
我甚至不觉得这是个委婉的邀请。我觉得它是一个，我认为这是一个“非邀请式”的邀请。一个假设性的邀请。是的。好吧。是啊。为什么不活在假设中呢？不，不。
Well, fast fact number one, or perhaps I should call it trivia number one, because this will be a little trivia for all of you office lovers. This episode was originally called Clicks. Oh yeah, yeah. Called Clicks, yeah. Well, I still have my copy of Clicks, and I re-read it. That's right. Talk about digital clutter,
好吧，第一条趣味冷知识，或者也许我应该称它为第一条冷知识，因为这对所有《办公室》爱好者来说会是一个小知识。这一集最初叫做《小团体》。哦，对，对。叫做《小团体》，是啊。好吧，我仍然留着我的《小团体》剧本副本，我还重新读了它。没错。说到数字杂物，
who's showing up today with the digital clutter. You are. Well, it's very different. First of all, the storyline with Dwight going to interview in Florida, it's all in there. That was the same. Okay. But back at the office, here's what happens.
今天是谁带着数字杂物来的？是你。好吧，这很完全不同。首先，德怀特去佛罗里达面试的剧情线，全都在里面。那是完全一样的。好吧。但是在办公室里，发生的事情是这样的。
Kelly finds out that Kathy and Aaron hung out over the weekend and she is not having it. Oh, she was left out. She goes to Andy and she says there are clicks in this office and you need to do something about it. We can't have people hanging out outside of work, gossiping about work, although Kelly's never cared before. No, no. So Andy calls a group meeting to talk about it. And he says, listen, it's not against the rules
凯利发现凯西和亚伦周末一起玩了，而她绝对不能接受。哦，她被排挤了。她去找安迪说办公室里有小团体，你得管管这事。我们不能容忍人们在工作之外聚在一起，八卦工作上的事，尽管凯利以前从来不在乎。不，不。所以安迪召集了一次全员会议来讨论这件事。他说，听好了，和别人在工作之外聚在一起并不违反规定，
to hang out with people outside of work, but you can only do it in a way that doesn't exclude people and you can't gossip about work. And then he gives an example. He says, for example, this Saturday, I went to Jim and Pam's house, but it wasn't a click because there was no gossiping and then I left.
但你聚会的方式不能排挤其他人，而且你不能八卦工作上的事。然后他举了个例子。他说，比如说这个星期六，我去了吉姆和帕姆家，但这不算搞小团体，因为没有八卦，然后我就离开了。
And Aaron is like, oh my God, I went to Jim and Pam's house on Saturday and must have just missed you. I was there for dinner. But guess what? What? Darryl was also there for dinner. And Kathy was there for dinner. At Jim and Pam's house?
然后亚伦就说，天哪，我周六也去了吉姆和帕姆家，肯定刚巧错过了你。我去吃晚饭了。但你猜怎么着？什么？达里尔也去吃晚饭了。凯西也去吃晚饭了。在吉姆和帕姆家？
Yes, they invited everybody over to meet the baby and they explained, listen, we weren't trying to exclude people, but these are the people who expressed interest in meeting our baby. So we had them over. If you had expressed interest in meeting the baby, you could have come over too. Suddenly, everybody starts confessing
是的，他们邀请所有人过去见见宝宝，他们解释说，听着，我们并不是想排挤任何人，但这些人是表达过想见我们宝宝意愿的人。所以我们才请他们过来。如果你也表达过想见宝宝的意愿，你也可以过来。突然之间，每个人都开始坦白
who they hang out with outside of work. And this is when it is revealed that Oscar, Ryan, Jim and Toby are on a trivia team together. This is where trivia starts to make its way in to clicks. Andy decides that the best way to break down off his clicks is for them to all form a trivia team together. They're going to play as the Dunder Mifflin, Scranton, trivia team.
他们平时在工作之外都和谁一起玩。也就是在这个时候，奥斯卡、瑞恩、吉姆和托比被揭露他们一起组建了一个知识竞赛团队。这就是知识竞赛开始融入小团体情节的地方。安迪认为打破办公室小团体最好的方法就是让他们所有人一起组建一个知识竞赛团队。他们将作为邓德·米夫林斯克兰队参加比赛。
They do. There was a trivia element to clicks, but it was only at the very end. I got in touch with writer Steve Healey, and he said that after we did the table read for clicks, they got a network note that network said, we don't understand this idea of clicks. We don't understand what they would mean to the office. It's not clear to us. We don't get it. We don't get it basically. They're like, we don't get it. So, Steve Healey and Paul Lieberstein, they kind of agreed and they did this massive reimagining of this A storyline and they decided, let's just lean into the trivia night part. Like, that
他们确实这么做了。小团体情节中确实包含知识竞赛的元素，但它只出现在最后阶段。我联系了编剧史蒂夫·希利，他说在我们为《小团体》进行剧本围读后，他们收到了来自电视台的意见，电视台说，我们不理解小团体这个概念。我们不明白这对办公室意味着什么。这对我来说不清楚。我们不懂。基本上就是我们不懂。他们就像是，我们不懂。所以，史蒂夫·希利和保罗·利伯斯坦，他们算是达成了一致，对这个A故事线进行了大规模的重新构思，他们决定，不如就顺应知识竞赛之夜这个部分。就像，
part was so fun and it worked like that part. They were like, we get that. We get trivia night. And that is how it became the focus of the episode. Oh. But they only had a week to do that. Yeah, it's a big rewrite. We did the table read and one week later we started shooting and we get this new script called trivia. We're like, what?
那部分太有趣了而且效果很好。他们就觉得，我们懂这个。我们懂知识竞赛之夜。这就是它如何成为这一集核心内容的由来。哦。但他们只有一个星期的时间来完成这个。是的，这是一次大重写。我们进行了剧本围读，一个星期后我们就开始拍摄了，然后我们拿到了这个叫《知识竞赛》的新剧本。我们当时就想，什么？
Right. There you go. I like that. All right. Good fast fact. Thank you. Our trivia fact. Trivia fact number two.
没错。就是这样。我喜欢这样。好的。很好的趣味事实。谢谢。我们的冷知识。第二条冷知识。
Okay. Steve Healey, our writer, told me that he was very excited to lean into trivia because he used to play a lot of bar trivia when he lived in New York City back in 2003. He said it was just sweeping the East Village and the area around NYU where he lived and he said he would go with his roommate and they took it super seriously because the prize was a $25 bar tab. Hey. Yeah.
好吧。史蒂夫·希利，我们的编剧，告诉我他非常兴奋能倾心于知识竞赛，因为他住在纽约市2003年的时候经常玩酒吧知识竞赛。他说这简直席卷了东村和纽约大学他住的周边地区，他说他会和室友一起去，而且他们对待这事极其认真，因为奖品是25美元的酒吧消费额度。嘿。是啊。
He was like, we needed that. Yeah. He said they also had a couple of ringers that they would bring along. They had this friend who was a super smart attorney who would come out once a month for the big game. How fun! I want to be the ringer at trivia night.
他当时就说，我们需要那个。是的。他说他们还带了几个高手去。他们有个朋友是个超级聪明的律师，每个月会出来参加一次重大比赛。多有趣啊！我想成为知识竞赛之夜的高手。
I mean, it will never happen, but that's so cool. He said this was fun because he got to write what he knew. Oh, and I always love when the scripts come from someone's personal experience. Yeah. All right. Well, speaking of trivia nights, fast act number three, Angela, you said you did a little digging around about office trivia nights. Yeah, which are very popular. They're super popular. You can basically look up your city and type in the office trivia night. Yeah, which are very popular. They're super popular. You can basically look up your city and type in the office trivia night near me
我的意思是，这永远不会发生，但这太酷了。他说这很有趣，因为他可以写自己熟悉的东西。哦，我总是很喜欢剧本来源于某人的个人经历。好的。说到知识竞赛之夜，第三个趣味事实，安吉拉，你说你对办公室知识竞赛之夜做了一点研究。是的，它们非常受欢迎。它们超级受欢迎。你基本上可以查一下你的城市，然后输入“我附近的办公室知识竞赛之夜”，
and things are gonna come popping up. Yeah, trust me. I did one for my area and Jenna coming up, not too far from us, is a painting with the twist trivia night. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Am I gonna paint a picture while doing office trivia? Uh-huh. It is really popular.
然后各种活动就会弹出来。是的，相信我。我为我所在的地区查过一个，詹娜，离我们不太远的地方，有一个“绘画与微醺”（Painting with a Twist）知识竞赛之夜。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。我要一边画画一边参加办公室知识竞赛吗？嗯哼。这真的很受欢迎。
It's called Paper Company trivia. And on their website, it says, bring your office co-workers and your world's best boss mug and test your office knowledge at this Paper Company themed trivia night. Everyone paints the Dunderc Mifflin office building. I want us to go. I know. We have to show up at this point. I'm telling you, the sad part is I think we'll lose. Even though we've been doing good since we've done this much better.
它叫做“纸业公司知识竞赛”。在他们的官网上写着，带上你的办公室同事和你的“世界最佳老板”马克杯，在这个纸业公司主题的知识竞赛之夜测试你对办公室的了解。每个人都要画邓德·米夫林办公大楼。我想让我们去。我知道。我们到时必须得去。跟你说，可悲的是我觉得我们会输。尽管我们自从做了这个节目以来一直表现不错，比以前好多了。
Remember our trivia with Billy Eilish? I was a stinker. You did not do well that day. You did horribly. I did horrible when we did it on the today show. I froze. I know. This is the problem. We could freeze, but we would also be painting and having a glass of wine, I think. How many people do you need for a team? I don't know. Does it say?
还记得我们和比利·艾利什一起玩的知识竞赛吗？我当时像个废柴。那天你表现得可真不好。你表现得太糟糕了。我们在《今日秀》上玩的时候我表现得太糟糕了。我整个人都僵住了。我知道。这就是问题所在。我们可能会僵住，但我想我们也会一边画画一边喝着红酒。一个团队需要多少人？我不知道。上面写了吗？
All right, I will dig deeper. I just was very excited that we got to paint and do office trivia. Well, find out because I think we could maybe recruit a couple of other office mates. Oh, I bet Kate would go with us. And Oscar would be good. Probably Creed.
好吧，我会深入了解一下。我只是很高兴我们能去画画并参加办公室知识竞赛。好吧，查清楚，因为我觉得我们或许可以招募其他几个办公室同伴。哦，我敢打赌凯特会和我们一起去。奥斯卡也会很厉害。还有克里德。
Creed, you know, came to my 50th birthday painting party where we painted hummingbirds and he painted a little alien ship with his hummingbirds. We were like, wait, where are the aliens? Well, you know who'd be horrible at a trivia night is Rainwellson. And Rain, I'm sorry to say this,
克里德，你知道的，来参加了我50岁生日的绘画派对，我们在那儿画蜂鸟，而他在他的蜂鸟旁边画了一个小飞碟。我们当时就想，等等，外星人在哪儿？好吧，你知道谁在知识竞赛之夜会表现得很糟糕吗？雷恩·威尔森。雷恩，我很抱歉这么说，
but you never remember anything. You're not wrong. I'm like, oh my gosh, Rain, remember that episode where you get hit by the car and you throw up on the hood. He's like, what? I'm like, what? I'm like, watch it. Yeah.
但你从来记不住任何事。你没说错。我就会说，哦天哪，雷恩，还记得你被车撞到然后吐在引擎盖上的那一集吗？他就会说，什么？我就说，什么？我就说，看一看。是啊。
Once he rewatches it, he gets all these ideas, but like, he has no trivia knowledge of the office. None. Brian Baumgartner might be good. Brian would kick some butt. And then also, you guys, if you love office trivia, Dave Keckner is hosting trivia nights. He travels around to different bars and will put the swipe up in our stories, but it says test your knowledge of the office with the Pac-Man himself,
一旦他重新看了，他就会冒出所有这些想法，但是，他对办公室一点知识竞赛储备都没有。一点也没有。布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳可能会很不错。布莱恩会大显身手的。然后还有，伙计们，如果你喜欢办公室知识竞赛，戴夫·科克纳正在主持知识竞赛之夜。他四处奔波去不同的酒吧，我们会在快拍里放上上滑链接，上面说和吃豆人本尊一起测试你对办公室的了解，
David Keckner, teams compete for prizes while also hearing behind-the-scenes stories from David about playing the hit shows favorite obnoxious paper salesman. That's pretty cool. I know. Well, listen, why don't we take a break and when we get back, we're gonna have total silence. We won't speak for 14 minutes. Enjoy that in your commute. We'll be right back. We are back from break. While we were on break, we decided our trivia team is gonna be our office ladies team.
大卫·科克纳，团队为赢取奖品而竞争，同时还能听到大卫分享关于扮演这部热门剧中最令人讨厌的纸业推销员的幕后故事。这太酷了。我知道。听着，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来，我们将保持绝对安静。我们有14分钟不说话。你们在通勤路上好好享受吧。我们马上回来。我们休息回来了。在休息期间，我们决定我们的知识竞赛团队就是我们的办公室辣妈团队。
Sam, Cassie, get ready. Polish up your the office trivia and get your paint brushes because I think we've all gotta go. We're ready. Listen, they watch it every week just like we do. I know. This is the team. This is actually win now.
萨姆，卡茜，准备好。温习一下你们的办公室知识竞赛知识，准备好你们的画笔，因为我觉得我们都得去。我们准备好了。听着，他们每周都看，就像我们一样。我知道。这就是这个团队。这实际上现在就能赢。
Team office ladies. Yeah, I'm excited. Oh my gosh, this is so crazy if we really did that That's so crazy. We're gonna do it. What if we won? That would be I feel like people would be angry That's not fair. It's rigged All right, listen this cold open is very very very very quiet. No one is speaking In fact, people are signaling to each other to
办公室辣妈队。耶，我很兴奋。哦天哪，如果我们真的这么做了，那就太疯狂了。太疯狂了。我们要去。如果我们赢了呢？那会……我觉得人们会生气的。这不公平。有内幕。好吧，听着，这段开场白非常非常非常非常安静。没有人说话。事实上，大家都在互相打手势来
keep quiet. Don't talk. We had a fan question from Jacqueline Kay and San Diego who said, a few episodes back, you were talking about the longest silence on the office. You both agreed that it was Jim and Pam on the boat in Boose Cruise, but when this cold open technically be the episode with the longest silence. Well done. Yes, Jacqueline. Well done, Jacqueline. Well done, Jacqueline. I timed it.
保持安静。别说话。我们收到了来自圣地亚哥的杰奎琳·K的一个粉丝提问，她说，几集前，你们谈到了《办公室》里最长的沉默。你们都同意那是《游船派对》里吉姆和帕姆在船上的场景，但是这段开场白严格来说难道不是拥有最长沉默时间的剧集吗？干得好。是的，杰奎琳。干得好，杰奎琳。干得好，杰奎琳。我计时了。
It's one minute and twenty two seconds. Oh, yeah. This is it. This is it. This cold open reminded me a lot of earlier seasons when the whole bullpen would get in on some prank together. Mm-hmm. I loved it.
是一分钟二十二秒。哦，是的。就是这个。就是这个。这段开场白让我想起了前几季，当时整个办公室的人都会一起参与一些恶作剧。嗯哼。我太喜欢了。
Yeah. Well, Andy's having a really hard time during this game of being silent because he sees a raccoon eating a burger out of a paper bag in the parking lot. He is trying so hard to like act out what he's seeing because this is crazy. He needs to share it with someone. He needs to share it with someone. This whole scene all I could think about was Sam because Sam loves raccoons. I don't know, Sam. You might have watched more raccoon videos than any person ever.
是啊。好吧，安吉拉在这场保持安静的游戏中过得非常艰难，因为她看到停车场里有一只浣熊正在从纸袋里掏汉堡吃。他极力想把看到的演出来，因为这太疯狂了。他需要跟别人分享。他需要跟别人分享。整个场景我脑子里想的全是萨姆，因为萨姆喜欢浣熊。我不知道，萨姆。你可能看过的浣熊视频比任何人都多。
I bet I might have. I mean, if you go to Sam's Insta Stories, it's almost all raccoon shenanigans. They're just, they're perfect. They're all fat and chubby and they have little squirmy hands and baby eyes. I want to know, Sam. What's the craziest thing you've seen a raccoon do. Hmm. I think I'm drawn to the videos where it's like a dumpster and somebody knocks on the dumpster and then the lid opens and there's like 60 to 70 raccoons in there. Like an insane amount of raccoons. There's just thousands of them in there. Those always get me. Will you send me one of those that I could share in our stories? I certainly will. I absolutely have some saved on my phone.
我敢说我可能真的看过。我的意思是，如果你去看萨姆的Instagram快拍，几乎全都是浣熊的恶作剧。它们太完美了，胖乎乎的，有着扭来扭去的小手和婴儿般的眼睛。我想知道，萨姆。你见过浣熊做过最疯狂的事情是什么？嗯。我觉得我比较被那种场景吸引，就是有人在一个垃圾箱旁边敲垃圾箱，然后盖子打开，里面有60到70只浣熊。数量多到疯狂的浣熊。里面有成千上万只。那种视频总是能吸引我。你能发我一个那样的视频让我分享到我们的快拍里吗？我当然可以。我手机里绝对存了一些。
Okay, that was our Sam Raccoon moment of the day. Thank you for checking in. You're welcome. When I was in New York, I was walking through Central Park and I saw a raccoon doing something funny and I was like, I need to send this to Sam. I know. So I videoed and sent him a raccoon. Now I don't remember what it was doing, but not as interesting as what you just described. That update made my day. Oh, good.
好吧，那是我们今天的“萨姆浣熊时刻”。谢谢你的分享。不客气。当我在纽约的时候，我正走在中央公园里，我看到一只浣熊在做一件很有趣的事，然后我就想，我得把它发给萨姆。我知道。所以我拍了视频发给了一只浣熊。现在我不记得它在干什么了，但没有你刚才描述的那么有趣。那个更新让我一整天都很开心。哦，太好了。
Well, I have to tell you, Angela, there is a moment in this cold open that caused a fan mail flurry. And I investigated it. I have no answer and it's driving me crazy. I want to know. Okay, it's the gym talking head. Okay, where he explains what they're doing
好吧，我得告诉你，安吉拉，这段开场白里有一个瞬间引发了粉丝来信的狂潮。我调查过了。我没有答案，这快把我逼疯了。我想知道。好吧，就是吉姆的单人采访。好吧，他在那儿解释他们在做什么，
and he has the note paddy holds up. And yes, they're on a silent streak. This is their biggest record, 14 minutes. Yes, so when he first holds up the sheet of paper, it says like no one has spoken in dot, dot, dot. He looks at his watch. He turns the pad of paper over rights 14 minutes. And then he holds it back up again for the camera.
他手里举着那个便签本。是的，他们正在进行静音连胜。这是他们最大的纪录，14分钟。是的，所以当他第一次举起那张纸时，上面写着“没有人说话已经……点点点”。他看了一下手表。他把便签本翻过来，写下14分钟。然后他又把便签本举起来对着镜头。
Tegan L, from Great Barrington, Massachusetts, said, I have been waiting since the beginning of this podcast to ask this. Wow, Tegan, this is a long wait. In the cold open, when Jim writes down 14 minutes with two strokes underneath to emphasize the point, the sound does not match that many strokes. And from the time he puts his paper down to write,
来自马萨诸塞州大巴灵顿的泰根·L说，我从这个播客开播以来就一直在等着问这个问题。哇，泰根，这可等了够久的。在开场白中，当吉姆写下“14分钟”并在下面画两道杠来强调重点时，声音和画的笔画数根本对不上。而且从他放下纸开始写，
the time we see the paper again, it's less than two seconds. Even at my absolute fastest, it takes at least three seconds closer to four to write out 14 minutes with two strokes underneath. Tegan timed it. It's 11 strokes of a pen in order to write everything Jim wrote. Tegan says, my question is, did Jim write that out himself? Does he just write faster than I do?
到我们再次看到这张纸，时间不到两秒钟。即使以我绝对最快的速度，用两道杠在下面写完“14分钟”也至少需要三秒钟，接近四秒钟。泰根计时了。为了写完吉姆写的所有东西，一共需要11笔。泰根说，我的问题是，那是吉姆自己写的吗？他只是写得比我快吗？
Was it already written out? Anna S. from London also noticed this? Lady, it doesn't match. It doesn't match. The scribble sounds of the pen, they are not enough strokes to equal that amount. And also, there's no cut. There's no cut away. He doesn't match. The scribble sounds of the pen, they are not enough strokes to equal that amount. And also, there's no cut. There's no cut away.
还是早就写好了？来自伦敦的安娜·S也注意到了这一点？女士们，这根本对不上。根本对不上。笔摩擦的沙沙声，笔画数根本不够多，达不到那个数量。而且，中间没有剪辑。没有切走镜头。他根本对不上。笔摩擦的沙沙声，笔画数根本不够多，达不到那个数量。而且，中间没有剪辑。没有切走镜头。
He doesn't flip a page. I don't know how it's mystifying. It's confusing. And now I'm part of this. I'm a part of this with Tegan and also with Anna. Well, I thought when he was holding up that very first piece of paper, you know, that says the longest streak, Jimmy Colin. Yeah.
他没有翻页。我不知道这是怎么回事，太迷幻了。太让人困惑了。现在我也卷进去了。我和泰根以及安娜一样卷进去了。好吧，我以为他举起那张第一张纸的时候，你知道的，上面写着最长连胜记录的那个，吉姆……是的。
I thought I could see writing under. But he doesn't ever flip the page. How did he do it? He does flip the page. No, he doesn't flip it over. After he shows it, he brings it down, he writes something, he holds it back up again. There's no cut. There's no flip. There's no cut. There's no flip.
我以为我能看到下面有字。但他从来没有翻页。他是怎么做到的？他确实翻页了。不，他没有把它翻过来。在他展示完之后，他把它拿下来，他写了点东西，然后又把它举起来。没有剪辑。没有翻页。没有剪辑。没有翻页。
There's no flip. There's no cut. I don't get it. I can't figure it out. It's driving me nuts now. Someone tell me how he does it. I thought he flipped it over. He doesn't flip it over.
没有翻页。没有剪辑。我不明白。我搞不懂。这现在把我快逼疯了。谁来告诉我他是怎么做到的。我以为他把它翻过来了。他没有把它翻过来。
It's mad. I trust you and Tegan and Anna. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know. Maybe John has like crazy super fast fingers or something. I don't know. Well, they clearly added in sound effects. Yeah. Because the sound effects are or something. I don't know. Well, they clearly added in sound effects.
太疯狂了。我相信你、泰根和安娜。是的。是的。我不知道。也许约翰有疯狂的超级快的手速什么的。我不知道。好吧，他们显然是后期添加了音效。是的。因为音效是……或者什么的。我不知道。好吧，他们显然是后期添加了音效。
Yeah. Because the sound effects are not accurate. I don't know. We also had a fan question from George P. a New Hampshire who says when Aaron asks for a first aid kit during the cold open, she has clearly cut her hand. Why did the safety officer Angela Martin or assistant to the safety officer Dwight K. Shrut
是的。因为音效根本不准确。我不知道。我们还收到了来自新罕布什尔州的乔治·P的粉丝提问，他说，当亚伦在开场白中要急救包时，她的手明显割破了。为什么安全员安吉拉·马丁或者安全员助理德怀特·K·施鲁特
not jump up and offer to help her? I want to create a little backstory here that doesn't exist. Okay. I want to say that Aaron harms herself fairly regularly in the office and Angela has just given up and probably left a kit somewhere for her because Aaron's just such a clutz. Such a clutz. Angela's like, I'm done. It's over there if you need anything. Mm-hmm, yeah. The episode is going to begin in the conference room. Andy is writing down things that can be done with paper on the whiteboard. I loved that by the way.
没有跳出来帮忙呢？我想在这里编一点不存在的小背景故事。好吧。我想说的是，亚伦在办公室里经常不小心弄伤自己，安吉拉已经放弃了，可能随手给她留了个医疗箱，因为亚伦实在是太笨手笨脚了。太笨手笨脚了。安吉拉就像是，我不管了。你要是需要什么，就在那边。嗯哼，是的。这一集将从会议室开始。安迪在白板上写着用纸可以做的事情。我顺便说一句，我很喜欢这个。
He's using a whiteboard to talk about how much you need paper. Exactly. I just thought that was a great touch. That was very funny. So this is what is written down so far. Ransome notes, anonymous threats, paper airplanes, love letters, books, and the infinity sign.
他用白板来讨论纸张是多么必需。没错。我只是觉得这真是一个绝妙的点子。非常搞笑。所以目前上面写的是这些：勒索信、匿名威胁、纸飞机、情书、书本和无穷大符号。
Andy is doing this so his own employees will purchase paper from the company because there's a gap in his sales goal. They have to sell $830 worth of more paper so that they can reach their sales goal. So he would like everyone in the room to please buy some paper. And apparently Andy's been buying paper for a while. Yeah, he has like $2,200 worth of paper and his garage.
安迪这么做是为了让自己的员工从公司买纸，因为他的销售目标有缺口。他们必须再卖出价值830美元的纸才能达成销售目标。所以他希望房间里的每个人都能买一些纸。而且显然安迪已经买纸好一阵子了。是的，他车库里有价值2200美元的纸呢。
For my background catch folks, during Andy's talking head in the parking lot, it was very foggy. We got mail about that. People wondered if there were any fires in the area causing that smoke. That was a question we got. But I couldn't figure out how to find that information. I think it was just really early. I think it was first thing of the day. We do have that here. We have that marine layer. Yeah. There wasn't Andy talking head alt that might have happened here. It's in deleted scenes.
关于我的背景彩蛋，在停车场安迪的单人采访期间，雾非常大。我们收到了关于这个的邮件。大家想知道周围是否有火灾导致了那场烟雾。这是我们收到的一个问题。但我搞不懂怎么找到那个信息。我觉得当时只是太早了。我觉得那是天刚亮的时候。我们这儿确实有那种天气。我们有那种海洋层。是的。这里本来可能还有一个安迪的单人采访备用片段。在删减片段里。
And I couldn't help but think of Phil Shay. So Andy has a talking head where he's describing all the paper he needs to sell. But he also says, you can use all this extra paper to make an amateur animation book. Okay. And he has a detailed animation book that he's made. In the script, it says, Andy shows a flip book he made showing a stick figure labeled Andy shaking hands with
我忍不住想到了菲尔·谢伊。所以安迪有一个单人采访，他在里面描述了他需要卖掉的所有纸。但他也说，你可以用所有这些多余的纸来做一个业余动画书。好的。他做了一本详细的动画书。在剧本中写着，安迪展示了他制作的一本翻页动画书，上面画着一个标有“安迪”的火柴人正和
a stick figure labeled Robert. Then exclamation points appear above their heads as they do a celebration dance. Robert's stick figure says, I am so proud of you. And the 8% like exclamation point symbol dances over their heads and they're dancing. They're so happy. It's, I mean, probably a hundred pages of stick figures that you flip to make this little thing play out. And I was like, oh my gosh, Phil Shea had to make this whole animated flip book for a talking head that wasn't even used. Oh my gosh. But it's indelated. Yes. So Phil, I did watch it and I saw it and it was really cute.
一个标有“罗伯特”的火柴人握手。然后他们头顶上方出现了感叹号，他们跳起了庆祝舞蹈。罗伯特的火柴人说：“我为你感到骄傲。”那个代表8%的类似感叹号的符号在他们头顶跳舞，他们在跳舞。我的意思是，大概有一百页的火柴人，你翻动它就能让这个小短片播放出来。当时我就想，天哪，菲尔·谢伊竟然得为一个甚至都没用上的单人采访制作整本动画翻页书！天哪。但它在删减片段里。是的。所以菲尔，我确实看了，我看到了，真的超可爱。
Well, next up Dwight is going to pull up to the saber headquarters. He's showing up in a cab. I got the location details from Steve Burgess. He said, we shot this at Baxter Pharmaceuticals and Thousand Oaks. It is a huge office complex and we did all of the shooting there. We did not build anything for this location. We shot the exterior drop-off, the lobby with that crazy floor palm tree. Yes. And all of the office interiors. Dwight is super pumped. He's walking through, he shoved someone, he does like one of his
接下来德怀特将把车开到萨布丽总部。他是坐出租车来的。我从史蒂夫·伯格斯那里得到了拍摄地点细节。他说，我们在千橡市的巴克斯特制药公司拍摄的。这是一个巨大的办公综合体，我们所有的镜头都在那里拍的。我们没有为这个取景地搭建任何东西。我们拍摄了外部下车处、带有那个疯狂地板棕榈的大堂。是的。以及所有的办公室内部。德怀特超级兴奋，他走着走着，撞了某个人，他还做了一个
high kicks in the air. And then he announces himself to the receptionist. I couldn't get enough of the saber corporate receptionist. I just thought she was amazing. Everything she said made me laugh. Well we got some mail from Sydney B and Toledo Ohio who agrees with you, who said, I have always been obsessed with the receptionist in Florida. Her character makes me laugh so hard and I want to know everything about her. Well, her name is Laurel Coppuk and she has been on Modern Family. She was in Crazy Stupid Love. She played Jeff Garland's assistant in season 6 of Curbure Enthusiasm. She's in the main company of the groundlings in LA, but she is probably best known as Toyota Spokesperson Jan. Oh, she's done a string of commercials.
高空侧踢。然后他向接待员报上名来。我对萨布丽总部的接待员简直喜爱得不够。我只是觉得她太棒了。她说的每一句话都让我发笑。好吧，我们收到了来自俄亥俄州托莱多的悉尼·B的邮件，她和你的看法一样，她说，我一直对佛罗里达的那位接待员着迷。她的角色让我笑得前仰后合，我想知道关于她的一切。好吧，她的名字叫劳尔·科普克，她曾出演过《摩登家庭》。她出演过《疯狂愚蠢的爱》。她在《抑制热情》第六季中扮演杰夫·加兰的助理。她是洛杉矶地面lings剧团的主演成员，但她最广为人知的可能还是丰田汽车的代言人简。哦，她拍过一连串的广告。
I looked into this, it was really cool. In the middle of this campaign, she got pregnant and then Jan got pregnant and she's just like a fan favorite. Oh wow. Steve Healy, our writer brought her up. He said they actually added more stuff for her during this episode because she was so fun to work with and so funny.
我查了一下，真的很酷。在这个广告活动进行到一半时，她怀孕了，然后简也怀孕了，她简直成了粉丝的最爱。哦，哇。我们的编剧史蒂夫·希利提起了她。他说他们这一集实际上为她加了更多戏份，因为跟她合作太有趣了，她也太搞笑了。
He said she just put this spin on the roll that they really loved, which was that she was doing her best to tolerate Gabe and that inside she was actually rooting for Dwight because she sensed he was Gabe's enemy. So that was like just something that was for her to know about her character. But when you make a little decision like that, I feel like it comes off, you know? She's great.
他说她只是为这个角色注入了一种他们非常喜欢的特质，那就是她尽最大努力去容忍加布，而内心里她其实是在暗中支持德怀特，因为她感觉到德怀特是加布的死对头。所以这就像是只有她自己知道的关于她角色的一个小设定。但当你做出这样的小决定时，我觉得效果就会呈现出来，对吧？她太棒了。
She is. She reminded me of like a second grade teacher when she was like how frustrating for you. Yes. Do we want to talk about our feelings? Yes. We also got a fan catch from Ryan C. in Mexico. He noticed that there's a hole in the wall behind Stephanie's desk. And there is.
她确实很棒。她让我想起了一个二年级老师，当她说“这对你来说是多么令人沮丧啊”的时候。是的。我们想聊聊我们的感受吗？是的。我们还收到了来自墨西哥的瑞安·C的一个粉丝彩蛋。他注意到斯蒂芬妮桌子后面的墙上有个洞。确实有。
There's a hole behind her. It's over her right shoulder. OK. He wanted to know what happened. I don't know Ryan. But now every time we cut to her, I see the hole in the wall. This is what happened to me in this episode. People wrote in, they pointed things out, and then you couldn't unsee them. Correct. So I'm passing
她身后有个洞。在她的右肩膀上方。好的。他想知道发生了什么。我不知道，瑞安。但现在每次镜头切到她，我都看到墙上的洞。这就是我在这一集里遇到的情况。大家写信指出一些事情，然后你就再也忽视不了了。没错。所以我把
that along. There's going to be a very funny moment now between Gabe and Dwight. As Dwight sort of takes in where Gabe sits, and he says he's surrounded by shrubbery like a squirrel's office. That just cracked me up. Gabe is going to have a talking head. We've spoke about this talking head before because it was in deleted scenes for another episode. Yeah, but he's gonna explain how often he has to fly back from Scranton to Florida and back and forth. And also he has this fear of flying. So what a better way to tackle that.
这个发现传达给大家。加布和德怀特之间接下来会有一个非常搞笑的时刻。当德怀特打量着加布的座位时，他说加布被灌木丛包围着，就像松鼠的办公室一样。这真的把我逗乐了。加布会有一个单人采访。我们之前讨论过这个单人采访，因为它在另一集的删减片段里出现过。是的，但他会解释他不得不经常从斯克兰顿飞到佛罗里达两头跑的频率。而且他还有恐高症。所以还有什么比这更好的方式来克服它呢。
Robert is gonna show up and is surprised to see Dwight and says, you know what? He'll be with him shortly. Let me settle in. Mm-hmm. There was a Robert Deleted Talking Head where he shares his assessment of where Dwight is at within the company.
罗伯特将要出现，看到德怀特时感到很惊讶，并说，你知道吗？他稍后会接待他。让我先安定下来。嗯哼。有一个罗伯特的删减单人采访，他在里面分享了他对德怀特在公司所处位置的评估。
And he references the Peter Principle. Okay. Yeah, I've never heard of this. Let's hear the clip and then I'll tell you what the Peter Principle is. There's a funny law of business known as the Peter Principle. Every employee gets promoted until he reaches the level of his incompetence. Right now Dwight, as a salesman, has reached his highest level of competence.
他提到了彼得原理。好的。是的，我从来没听说过这个。我们听听这段剪辑，然后我再告诉你什么是彼得原理。商界有一个有趣的规律叫彼得原理。每个员工都会得到晋升，直到他达到他无能的水平。现在德怀特作为一名销售员，已经达到了他能力的最高点。
Now he's feeling the pull of moving up or moving on. My job is to make sure that neither of those happens. Wow. Yeah. Isn't that interesting? And I looked it up and it's a real thing. It's a real sort of theory within business, the Peter principle. It's this paradoxal idea that competent employees will continue to be promoted but at some point will be promoted into positions for which they are in fact incompetent
现在他感受到了向上流动或继续前进的拉力。我的工作就是确保这两者都不会发生。哇。是的。是不是很有趣？我查了一下，这是个真实存在的现象。商业领域中一种真实的理论，彼得原理。这是一个悖论式的观点，即有能力的员工会不断得到晋升，但在某个时刻会被晋升到他们实际上并不胜任的岗位上，
and then they will remain in those positions because they don't do them well. Wait, so you get to keep moving up and doing well and doing well and doing well, but then the job you end up in is one you can't do well. Is one that you weren't qualified to do. Which you only find out once you get the position, but you can't be demoted, so then you just stay in this role that you aren't really fit for. Wow, that is blowing my mind. Yeah.
然后他们就会一直呆在这些岗位上，因为他们做不好这些工作。等等，也就是说你不断往上走，表现很好，表现很好，表现很好，但你最终落脚的工作却是你做不好的工作？是你根本不具备资格去做的工作。而这一点只有当你坐上这个位置后才会发现，但你又不能被降职，所以你就只能呆在这个并不真正适合你的职位上。哇，这简直颠覆了我的认知。是的。
So sometimes I feel like if you run into someone who's in a position that they seem totally out of their depth and you're like, how did they get this job? Maybe they just got promoted it. Yeah, they were really good at all the other jobs that led up to it. Yeah, it's called the Peter Principle. Oh, I feel like I know some Peter principles. I do. I've come across some of those. I know. Am I a Peter principle? No. At what? I don't know. That's what I'm asking myself. I'm sure I've Peter principled some time in my life where I've gotten some job and then I was ill-equipped. Oh, I mean, for sure. I mean, there's been a few jobs I had where really I should have just been
所以有时我觉得，如果你遇到一个似乎完全无法胜任其职位、让你觉得“他们是怎么得到这份工作的”的人，也许他们只是被彼得原理了。是的，他们在通往这个职位之前的其他所有工作上都表现得非常出色。是的，这叫彼得原理。哦，我觉得我认识一些彼得原理的受害者。我也是。我遇到过这样的人。我知道。我是个彼得原理案例吗？没有。在哪方面？我不知道。这就是我在问自己的。我确信我生命中的某个时刻也经历过彼得原理，当时我得到了一份工作，然后我发现自己才疏学浅。哦，我是说，肯定的。我的意思是，我有过几份工作，实际上我本来应该只当个
like a spokesperson and then I got promoted to where I actually had to use the skill sets of things I talked about that I couldn't really implement. Well, I loved that. That was very interesting. Back in Scranton, Andy is going to approach Oscar. And he's hoping that Oscar can make a little rounding error. He wants Oscar to basically cook the books and cover up the fact that he's $830 short this quarter. But you know what, Oscar can't cook the books for Andy today because he's got to get to Trivia-Occalips. That's a mouthful. That's what he said. Kevin offers to do it. Kevin's happy to make a rounding error.
代言人，然后我却被提拔到了不得不使用我所讨论过的、但我实际上无法真正落地的技能的岗位上。好吧，我很喜欢这个。这非常有趣。回到斯克兰顿，安迪将走向奥斯卡。他希望奥斯卡能制造一点凑整误差。他想让奥斯卡做假账来掩盖他本季度销售额还差830美元的事实。但你知道吗，奥斯卡今天可不能为安迪做假账，因为他得去参加“知识竞赛末日大对决”。这名字真拗口。他是这么说的。凯文主动提出代劳。凯文很乐意制造凑整误差。
He does it all the time probably. This is when Andy is going to find out that the prize for Trivia-Colips is a thousand dollars. A thousand bucks? That's a big prize. This gives Andy an idea. Does? I mean, Steve Healy only got twenty-five dollars at the bar when he won. I know. $1,000. Well, Andy now sees his opportunity. He's going to try to get a group together to go to Trivia Knight. So he's talking to Jim and Darryl in his office,
他可能经常这么干。就在这个时候，安迪发现“知识竞赛末日大对决”的奖金是一千美元。一千大洋？那可是个大奖。这给了安迪一个主意。是吗？我的意思是，史蒂夫·希利当年在酒吧赢的时候才拿了二十五美元。我知道。一千美元。好吧，安迪现在看到了机会。他打算组织一个团队去参加知识竞赛之夜。所以他在办公室里和吉姆、达里尔谈这事，
and they're all in. So there were two things about this episode that caused a stir with fans. OK. One actually required NBC to make a press release. OK. Responding to the comments they received. That's later.
他们都同意了。所以这一集里有两件事在粉丝中引起了轩然大波。好吧。其中一件事甚至惊动了全国广播公司（NBC）发表了一份新闻稿。好吧。来回应他们收到的评论。那是后话。
Okay. Save that. Okay. But the other one was the fact that Jim agrees to go to Philadelphia without any concern for his wife. Oh. And they're newborn child at home. You can't wait to get out.
好的。那个先留着。好的。但另一件事是，吉姆居然毫不顾忌家里的妻子。哦。以及刚出生的小婴儿，就答应去费城。你简直迫不及待想离开。
There was so much mail about it. For example, I grabbed this one. This is like when the episode aired, I found this on officetelly.com. Robert wrote, quote, I just can't let go that Pam's ignored again. Even if Jenna isn't seen or heard, which I get, I have no problem with, Jim should still acknowledge Pam's existence, driving off to Philly without even a thought to his wife and infant son and toddler daughter defies belief to me, many letters of that nature. So when I was rereading clicks,
网上有太多关于这事的邮件了。比如，我抓取了这一封。这就像是剧集播出时，我在officetelly.com上找到的。罗伯特写道，引述：“我就是无法释怀帕姆再次被忽视。即使詹娜没有出镜或出声，这我能理解，我也毫无问题，吉姆依然应该承认帕姆的存在，开车去费城，对他的妻子、刚出生的婴儿和蹒跚学步的女儿连想都不想，这简直让我匪夷所思。”有很多这样性质的信件。所以当我重新阅读《小团体》时，
there was a storyline where everyone came to Jim and Pam's house. Yes! One of the things that I really liked was that Pam was mentioned, that a new baby was mentioned. And by the way, also in that script, it was revealed that Pam is the person who told Jim to invite Kathy because Pam suspected that Kathy might have a hard time fitting in with the group and she wanted her to be comfortable. I thought that was very interesting, but all of it got cut, you know, when the episode changed and Steve Healey actually said he wished that that reference to Pam back at home, he actually said he thought this episode would have been better with more Pam and Angela. Oh, well, thank you.
有一个剧情线是每个人都来到了吉姆和帕姆家。是的！我真的很喜欢的一点是，提到了帕姆，提到了新出生的宝宝。顺便说一句，同样在那份剧本中，揭示了帕姆才是那个告诉吉姆去邀请凯西的人，因为帕姆怀疑凯西可能很难融入集体，她想让凯西感到自在。我觉得这非常有趣，但所有这些都被剪掉了，你知道的，当剧集修改后，史蒂夫·希利实际上说过他希望保留对远在家中的帕姆的那个引用，他实际上认为如果这一集有更多帕姆和安吉拉的戏份会更好。哦，好吧，谢谢。
And he's not just saying that because he's on our podcast. Even if you are, Steve, thank you. But that was a big controversy that Jim seemed to have zero problems. No, Hall and ask. Made the decision to go prior to speaking with his wife at home. I wonder if I found a little scuttle butt thing as well. I wonder if it's our same scope. It happens later in the episode.
而且他这么说可不仅仅是因为他上了我们的播客。即使你是这么想的，史蒂夫，也谢谢你。但那是一个巨大的争议，因为吉姆似乎毫无问题……没有和家里商量。在和家里的妻子交谈之前就做好了离开的决定。我想知道我是不是也发现了一点八卦的小东西。我想知道这跟我们的是不是同一个梗。它发生在这一集的后面。
That's right. Okay, all right. Let's wait. We'll see if we can surprise each other. Okay. Back in the Saber lobby, Gabe is really given it to the bagel store. They better step it up.
没错。好的，好吧。我们等等。看看我们能不能给彼此一个惊喜。好吧。回到萨布丽大堂，加布正在对百吉饼店大加抱怨。他们最好加把劲。
Dwight's listening to this conversation and just kind of rolling his eyes. And this is when Gabe is going to share with Dwight that he considers himself the toilet of the office. He flushes away annoying problems. Yes, he's using that analogy as a compliment to himself that he's the toilet. Yeah, very interesting.
德怀特听着这段对话，只是翻了个白眼。也就是在这个时候，加布将对德怀特说，他认为自己是办公室里的马桶。他冲走了令人烦恼的问题。是的，他用这个比喻来称赞自己，说自己是马桶。是的，非常有意思。
Well, we had a fan question from Vivian A. in San Francisco who said, Hi, office ladies, my name is Vivian. I'm 13 years old and I absolutely love your podcast. Thank you, Vivian. My question is on Gabe's desk in Florida, you can see an SFU hat. Is this when we learned that that is the college
好吧，我们收到了来自旧金山的维维安·A的一个粉丝提问，她说，嗨，办公室辣妈，我叫维维安。我13岁了，我超级喜欢你们的播客。谢谢你，维维安。我的问题是，在加布位于佛罗里达的桌子上，你能看到一顶旧金山大学（SFU）的帽子。这是我们得知那是加布就读的大学的时候吗？谢谢。好吧，好眼力，维维安。我们可以从加布的桌子上了解到很多信息。不过，我得说，我觉得加布的桌子并没有反映出和他公寓相同的兴趣。还记得我们做观影派对那一集吗？我原本期待看到更多关于他旅行的东西。
that Gabe attended? Thank you. Well, great catch, Vivian. We can learn a lot from Gabe's desk. However, I have to say, I don't think that Gabe's desk reflected the same interests as his condo. Remember when we did viewing party? I was expecting to see more from his travels.
是的，是的。但我确实看到了那顶帽子。除了帽子，他还放了一张骑马骑士的框装照片。他有一些非常巨大的回形针。是的，我不知道他用那些来干嘛。而且他还放了一个——我想指出这一点——一个带框的奖章。我稍后会详细讨论这个。是的，因为他稍后会再次出场。显然有人用一个抽屉专门装这些东西。没错。我也看到了。
Yeah, yeah. But I did see the hat. In addition to the hat, he has a framed photo of a night on a horse. He has some very giant paper clips. Yeah, I don't know what he's using those for. And he also has, I want to point this out, a framed medal. I'm going to discuss more about that later. Yes, because he's going to surface later. Someone keeps a drawer of them, apparently. That's right. I saw that as well.
好吧，罗伯特要把德怀特打发走了。他说，听着，我不能见你，但我的首席运营官比尔会见的。然后罗伯特立刻给加布打电话说，听着，别把这事推给比尔。就直接……别拿这事去烦比尔。别拿这事去烦比尔。听听德怀特的演讲，好吗？听听他的想法。现在德怀特不得不去面对“马桶男”了。好吧，我们的邓德·米夫林员工们马上就要到达酒吧参加知识竞赛之夜了。林氏员工们马上就要到达酒吧参加知识竞赛之夜，我觉得我们应该休息一下。等我们回来，我们将讨论奥斯卡的反应。
Well, Robert is going to ditch Dwight. He's going to say, listen, I can't meet with you, but Bill, my COO will. And then Robert immediately calls Gabe and says listen don't pass us on to bill. Just leave it right. Don't bother bill with this. Don't bother bill with this. Here Dwight's speech, okay? And just hear him out. And now Dwight has to face the toilet, man. Well, our Dundr Mifflin folks are about to arrive at the bar for trivia night. Ifland folks are about to arrive at the bar for trivia night, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, we will discuss Oscar's reaction.
是的。你们将听到我的朋友、来自密苏里州圣路易斯的肖恩·P的一个粉丝提问，他说，我们能知道知识竞赛酒吧的外景地吗？除了这一集，它也出现在《费城永远阳光灿烂》中。《费城永远阳光灿烂》的演员们明确表示，他们在某个时候开始在和《办公室》相同的摄影棚拍摄。所以这是一个最初为《办公室》搭建、后来又被《永远阳光灿烂》重复使用的假酒吧吗？不是的。
Yes. And you're going to hear from my friend a fan question from Sean P and St. Louis Missouri who said, can we have a location breakdown for the trivia bar? In addition to this episode, it also shows up in its always sunny and Philadelphia. The always sunny cast made it clear that at some point they started filming on the same stages as the office. So was this a fakie bar that was first built for the office and then used again for always sunny? No.
这是一个真实的地点，肖恩。我们没有搭建这个酒吧。这个酒吧叫“联邦”（The Federal）。它位于北好莱坞的兰克斯汉姆大道上。你现在依然可以去那里。我们使用主酒吧来拍摄知识竞赛环节。我们还使用了他们的后室酒吧来拍摄这一集的尾声，也就是我们的团队参加州锦标赛的地方。但“联邦”是一个很棒的外景地。它曾被用于许多其他节目，包括《费城永远阳光灿烂》。所以你确实看出来了。是的，《费城永远阳光灿烂》
This was a real location, Sean. We did not build this bar. This bar is called the Federal. It is on Lankersham Boulevard in North Hollywood. You can still go there. We use the main bar for the trivia contest. And we also use their backroom bar for the tag of this episode, where our team is at the state championships. But the federal is a great location. It's been used on a lot of other shows, including it's always sunny and Philadelphia. So you did spot that. And yes, always sunny and Philadelphia
肖恩，这是一个真实的地点。我们没有搭建这个酒吧。这个酒吧叫联邦酒吧。它位于北好莱坞的兰克谢姆大道上。你现在还可以去那里。我们使用主酒吧来进行冷知识问答比赛。我们还使用了他们后面的酒吧来拍摄这一集的结尾，当时我们的团队正在参加州锦标赛。但联邦酒吧是个好地方。它曾在许多其他节目中使用过，包括《费城永远阳光灿烂》。所以你确实认出来了。没错，就是《费城永远阳光灿烂》
took over our stages after we left. There's a little cross over there. So Andy and the Dundermiffling crew walk in, Oscar spots them and he's like, what are you doing here? I mean, wouldn't you react similarly? Is it true of all the way from Philadelphia? Yeah. And you know, he's like, I can't believe you guys did that.
our stages after we left. There's a little cross over there. So Andy and the Dundermiffling crew walk in, Oscar spots them and he's like, what are you doing here? I mean, wouldn't you react similarly? Is it true of all the way from Philadelphia? Yeah. And you know, he's like, I can't believe you guys did that.
And Daryl's like, well, sometimes and then Daryl kind of clocks the room and goes, wait, is this a gay bar? And Oscars like, yes, don't you wanna leave? And Andy's like, I do not wanna leave. I wanna win that trivia money. And Oscars like, really? You're gonna win at trivia night at a gay bar. He scoffs, he thinks his team's gonna like ace those guys.
Mm-hmm. Andy's gonna be like, all right guys, let's break into teams. You all know yourselves, put yourselves in the right group. We've got the A team, we've got the backups, and then the just for funds.
And Meredith's like, just for fun with me. Meredith knows. Everyone seems to sort of know where they fit in except for Kevin. Yes. You know, we had a fan question from Kathleen M. and Davidson North Carolina who said, I would love to know where they fit in except for Kevin. Yes. You know, we had a fan question from Kathleen M. and Davidson North Carolina who said, I would love to know which trivia team you guys would be on.
Angela Jenna, but also your characters. Would you be Dunder Mifflin A team, Dunder Mifflin B team, or the Just for Fun team? Well, Angela Martin clearly did not come. Right. Why did you want no teams? She was on no team. She doesn't want to participate in
bar games. Are you kidding? Yeah, I wonder where Pam would have ended up if she was there. I think B team. I think, you know, Angela Kinsey real life is just for fun team. Uh-huh, and I think Jenna Fisher real life. I think I'd put myself on the B team as well. Because I want to take it somewhat seriously. Like like I would be frustrated on a just for fun team where we're not trying. Yeah. But I wouldn't have confidence in my trivia knowledge to be on an A team. Yeah, I wouldn't want the pressure that being on the A team.
So I think Jenna and Pam are the same, we're B team. Yeah. Well, you know, you and I weren't there for the bar. We didn't get to film any scenes there, but I reached out to Brian Gattis who plays Oscar's teammate, Zander, because I was like, Brian, we've known each other for years, and I said, Brian, what was it like on the day in that bar?
Can you tell us any stories? And he had some fun stuff to share. That's so cool, Ange, I didn't know you knew him. Yeah, I've known Brian a really long time, and he sent in an audio clip, because Jenna, he's responsible for a very funny joke that made it in the episode. So after auditioning for the pilot
and multiple episodes of the office, I was totally psyched to finally be a guest star on such a cult show. All the series regulars were really sweet and they came up and introduced themselves to me on set, which makes stepping into this well-oiled TV machine so much less daunting as a guest star. As far as anything that sticks out in this episode was I actually pitched a joke on set,
which is not common as a guest star and also not very common to pitch a joke for another character. So in this episode, the trivia announcer bus B.J. for like being on his phone and says something to the fact of like, I'm sure you're just checking your dating account. And I was like, hmm, Grindr was an app that was fairly new in the gay world. So I asked Oscar, I was like, who's the writer? And I was like, do you think it would be okay if I would just could pitch a joke? And Oscar was like, yeah, sure, why not? So I went up to the writer and I said, hey, and he was like, hey, and I said,
I actually have a joke I want to pitch you. And he just looked at me with a blank face. I'm sure he was like, really? A guest star is going to pitch me a joke now, okay. And I said, you know, it's not for my character, it's for another character. And I think that made him a little even more intrigued. So I pitched him the grinder joke
and he immediately was like, what is that? And you know, I was like, oh clearly this guy is straight. So I told him what the grinder app was all about. And he was like, oh, that's actually pretty funny. So then he called BJA over who was actually the director of the episode. And I pitched BJA the joke and and BJ was like, that is funny. So all gay men would know what this app is. And I was like, yeah, they totally know what it is. And then BJ was like, Hey, Mindy. And so he pulled Mindy over and I pitched her
the joke. And Mindy was like, great, love it. So they actually shot it. And it was in the final episode, which was awesome. Other little things, like when we filled out the answer cards, they let us write in our own answers. So instead of Atlanta, I wrote Atlanta. Duh. Oh my God, I love that story so much. Oh, right. Yes.
Cracked me up. But also, I just love that everyone was like, so gay people will know what this grinder app is. I mean, it must have been very new at the time. I think we all know Grindr now, right? We all know. But I like that he was like, uh, yeah, just trust me. Yeah. Well, the trivia gets underway and it starts with our question about the capital state that was on Ray Charles's mind, Atlanta. Mm-hmm. And I wanted to give a shout out to our trivia announcer who was played by Dan Gill, who's a very funny comedian.
I went down a tiny rabbit hole looking at his stuff and one of the things that I found very funny was a story he told on a podcast where they asked him, what's kind of like an audition that you went on that was a total fail? Yeah, he said that there was an audition for a television show and in the breakdown The breakdown we should tell people is a casting director sends out to all the agents a description of the character
Yeah, the person they're looking for for this role and then the agents go through their files and they're like Who do I have who might match this description? I'll send them on an audition. The breakdown said looking for a Dan Gill type. Oh, so guess what? He got the audition. He did not get the role. Yeah. He didn't get it. Yeah.
But then later, they brought him back onto the show to play himself, Dan Gill. So that is the search of my story. But he's awesome. And he's so good in this episode. Yeah. The next trivia question was, quote, you're not an all-star of the NBA,
but you did get your game on when you won the NBA's sixth man of the year award in 2011. Who are you? Well, guess who's gonna get this one right? No one could guess. No one on our A team, no one on our B team, the just for funds. Kelly knows it's Lamar Odom. Yeah, because it was a really big storyline on Chloe and Lamar. I loved this. Well, Andy is going to start to freak out because the A team missed this question.
He really thought Darryl and Jim have this one. Yeah. I wouldn't have gotten this question. Same. I would have gotten Atlanta. Yes, I've gotten Atlanta. You know, it made me really curious about trivia questions. And I kind of went down the rabbit hole of like, what are some of the best trivia questions? There's so many websites that list top trivia questions. And what a lot of them have in common is a mix of information. So you really need a good mix of people on your team that are from different backgrounds and have different jobs or different interests
because the questions are all over the map on a good trivia night. That makes sense to me. I feel like you need a sports expert. You need someone who can handle pop culture. But then you need someone who knows just like historical facts. Yeah. Well, Andy thought he had all that and he didn't.
But it did make me curious if team office ladies could answer a few random assortment trivia questions that I found on the internet under most popular trivia questions. Okay. Sam, Cassie, get ready. I need to know this before we go to our painting trivia night. This is our test. Okay, we're ready. Okay.
Now, granted, our painting night, it's going to be all office trivia, but I. This is our test. Okay, we're ready. Okay. Now granted, our painting night, it's going to be all office trivia, but I think this is still important. Okay. How are we as a team? Okay. I tried to pick very random different questions. Okay. From this website. And, Angela, you just be honest. Just say if you would have gotten it right or not. Because you know the answer. I will be honest. I will be honest. Question number one, I will be honest. I will be honest. Question number one. What are the names of the four March sisters and little women? Oh gosh. Oh wow. I had nothing. In little women. Cassie. Someone named... Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Joe. Is there a Joe? Yep. Yep. Joe is there, um, oh dang it. I saw the movie.
Florent's pew. She's a sister. I don't know anybody. Sam Cassie. All right, I have nothing. Now, Angela, would you have gotten this right? I would have gotten three, and I probably would have forgotten the fourth one.
Okay, who are they? So Joe and Beth, Beth is who passes away. Okay. Amy's who goes abroad to France. Okay. I'm sorry, spoiler alert. Sorry. And then I think the one I would have forgotten is Meg.
Meg. Poor Meg. I know. The forgettable one. I know. Sorry Meg. Number two, in chess, which direction can a bishop move? I got this one, diagonally.
That's correct. Yes. Okay. I might have gotten that one, because Cade please chess all the time. All right, question number three. How many colors will you find in a regular bag of M&Ms? Six, I have to count.
Red, blue, green, yellow, brown, orange. I think it's six. Six is correct. Hey! I'm gonna tell you why I know that. I would not have known that. As a mom, when we hand out the M&Ms, they always want one of each color, has to be even.
And I had this immediate picture of like six MM's in my hands. My brain flashback. Do you remember when there was two browns? Yes, there was dark brown and light brown. I couldn't remember. They got rid of it for blue. They did. That's right. Okay. Gosh, I would not have known that at all. I'm very impressed with your knowledge of M&M's, all of you.
All right. Question number four. Which marine animal holds hands in their sleep to prevent drifting apart? Others. That's correct. Yeah. Isn't that the cutest thing they hold hands so sweet when they bought a sheep? Don't you want to be together? They also balance rocks on their bellies. They do. They're very cute. Why do they do that? They just, they just, they like it. Yeah, they juggle rocks on their bellies. Yeah. Oh my god.
We clearly we know a lot about sea otters. Okay. All right. Next question. Who was the first woman inducted into the rock and roll Hall of Fame? I have a guess. I have a guess.
All right. Let's hear them. I have a guess. All right. Let's hear them. I'm thinking Janice Joplin. I was thinking maybe Tina Turner. Okay. Final answer please. Kind of say Joan Jett, but that feels too late. Final answer or Bonnie Rate?
Would they take a wreath of Franklin? No. I know. I was, does Tina Turner qualify as rock and roll? Who is that? I want to say, Rita Franklin. Okay. Final answer please. Oh, we have to decide, team. Have we sent the name? Are we anywhere?
I can't give hints. Right on, right your answer out and hold it up. I can't give any answer. All right, let's do Tina. Really? I'm nervous. Final answer? Sure. Rita Franklin. Really? I'm nervous. Final answer? Sure.
Aretha Franklin. Oh, Sam has it. Sam. How are you? You trust me. OK. All right, last question. What was the first and still only horror movie
to win the Oscar for Best Picture? The shining. Excerci. Oh, exerci. Oh. I know you guys are looking at me. picture. The shining. Pictures. Oh, excerpts. I know you guys are looking at me. Uh, I don't know what horror movie one best picture first and still only one. I think the shining is a pretty good guess. What about Poltergeist?
Two. I don't know if that made it up to. Yeah. So I kind of knew for a while every best picture from 1970 to 1990. It was a weird thing I did in college where I watched every movie and I can't remember, is this when you decided not to use a calculator? Is it the same time or no, this was a different time period, but you can tell I was a lot of fun in college What I did instead of attending parties
All right, final answer. I like the shining okay, we can do the shiny Stanley Kubrick, right? Yeah, okay The answer is silence of the land. Oh Okay, that concludes our office ladies trivia. I hope you played along with us at home. I'm sure people at home were screaming at their videos. I'm horribly. I think we're just for fun, team. Sorry. Yeah. We're just for otters, team.
Yeah. That was funny. And while speaking of trivia questions and how you come up with trivia questions, Heather H. from California wants to know, how did they write this episode? Did they have to work backwards and tailor questions to the teams? Were there any good questions or answers that didn't make it? Well, I asked Steve Healy our writer and he said that Heather is exactly right.
They reverse engineered the script because they wanted the Einstein's to win. And they said, of course, Oscar is very sharp. And so we wanted to see him winning a little bit because they felt that it would further torture him if he was beat by just a little bit by the Einstein's. And Steve also said there's probably a file with dozens more questions somewhere. And he went through all his digital clutter looking for it. And he said, I am so bummed that I couldn't find it for you. I did love that one of the questions the Einstein's missed was the question about Albert Einstein. That was an amazing joke. Well, listen, meanwhile, back in Florida, Gabe has explained to Dwight that Bill, our COO,
will not be available. He's putting out a fire nine miles away. Gabe is going to listen to Dwight's pitch. The toilet. He's gone to the toilet. He has. And Dwight knows it, but he still commits. Well, listen, it becomes very clear to Dwight very quickly that Gabe is just flushing him. But he says, I'm a crap too big to flush or something. And he demands that Gabe take him to Robert, California's home. Yeah. We'll get to it. First, we need to discuss what's happening at the trivia night and the controversy that was created by one of our teams, the queer and steen bears. Is that your thing, Ange? I don't know.
I think mine is different. Oh, we have different tidbits. When we got here this morning, we thought we had the same surprise. Now I'm very interested. You're very interested. Me go first? Yeah.
Okay, well, we're gonna get an update on how the teams are in their standings. The host is gonna give the teams in order of their points. And as he announces each team, you get to see a shot of that team. Oh, it is the same. It is about a picture. Is this about someone on a team? Yes, there is a moment where we cut to the queer and steen bears. This is where all the guys act like bears. The third guy from the left wearing a green plaid shirt. Set off a fan reaction so big that NBC had to make a press release because people thought that this man was Steve Carell in disguise.
Yep, making a cameo on the episode. Sam Cassie, I have a picture. Yes, fans thought this was an uncredited cameo by Steve. Oh my God. Looks like Robin Hood. Whoa. We will put a picture up in office, ladies pod, because for the third time in this episode, once a fan point is something out to me, I became obsessed with it.
It was such a crazy thing. Did you read about it? I did read about it. And sorry, the way you set it up, I thought maybe the queer and steam bears had cheated or some time or the math was wrong or, and then people were like, they could be in the top three or whatever.
But yes, I did read about this. There was a whole scuttle butt after the episode aired. People were all over the message boards, thinking they spotted Steve. I pulled one of the comments from Pat M who said, quote, I think it was Steve because first of all, it looks like him with a fake beard and fake eyebrows. Plus, later on the show, when they showed that table again, he's the only member of the group that isn't seen.
I think this is an indication that Steve came to visit, did the cameo for one day, but didn't hang for the whole filming. This was the conspiracy. I love that in this scenario, Steve comes to the set, makes the effort to come. But then, dawns of fake beard and eyebrows? Mm-hmm. This is a lot of effort to sit in and just act like a bear for one shot, and then he's like,
that was fun I'm out of here. I really wish he would have now. Well, this really blew up so much so that NBC gave a quote to the Washington Post saying it was not Steve Carell. They had to announce it. Oh my gosh, that is so funny. Well, you know, when they list the top three teams, I became very curious about what the other teams were.
There's a lot of other teams. Do they have names? I went to the shooting draft because I figured this was something that writers would have had a lot of fun with and there are lots of other team names. Oh, let's hear them. Yes. In the script, the trivia host had a whole rundown of all the scores. It was a bigger speech. Oh, and this is what he would have said. The Quirance team bears with seven, Joey Trivia-Annie, get it? With seven, the impish and pracerios with three, two broke dorks with six,
late onset beaver fever with five, Dundermifflin, A team with four, DM backup team with three. Jason Sogakus, zero. Oh, Einstein's with eight, and the ladies Gaga with five. Ah, alright. We got a fan question from Alexa P and Oceanside New York who said, hi, Jen and Angela, I am 15 years old and I've been listening to office ladies pretty much since it started. For this episode, I have always wondered why isn't Kelly on the Dunder Mifflin A team?
When she clearly knows more about pop culture than anyone in the office, I feel like she would be my first choice to have on my team for trivia night. Same Alexa, I agree with you. And this is exactly what Andy is discovering. He has completely underestimated the people in his office and their use in a trivia night. I mean Meredith is about to throw down some great answers. Meredith is going to get one right. I mean, Aaron, who Meredith calls Princess Ding Dong, is going to get flying jib.
I mean, you know, I would have got that. I did love when they get to the speed round and they're like first team to ring in, gets to answer. And so Aaron rings in first and she's like, guys, I did my part. Look at the answer now. That was a very funny joke.
Yeah. Well, I think we should head back to Florida because Dwight is gonna to arrive at Robert's condo. This was an apartment complex in North Hollywood that was very close to the federal. Steve Burgess told me we shot at the federal during the day one day and then after we finished, we moved over to this condo complex. Yeah, Dwight and Gabe are going to arrive and Robert California is having a wrestling
lesson, I guess. Yeah, a wrestling workout with Stu, who was played by Peter Gannon. I wanted to know, is this person a real wrestler? You know, you get cast in a role. Yeah. And all he does is like wrestle real hard. I was like, what's the story?
I mean, you look like he knew what he was doing. Also, there's nothing funny here to me than what Robert looked like because he was that first kind of, like he looked like a turtle on his back. Yeah, he was trying to like flip the other guy over and flailing about. And that's a very small space, you guys.
Imagine watching two grown men wrestling as hard as they can but just like one foot in front of you. Yeah, like between a couch and a coffee table they've moved. Well, I found Peter Gannon's resume and it does not look like he is a wrestler. He listed many special skills which were martial arts like Wando, boxing, scuba diving, horseback riding, golf, baseball, skiing, both water and snow. So I reached out to Steve Burgess and Steve Burgess said, no, he is an actor they hired and both Peter and James met with our stunt coordinator Tom DeWire and they just spent the morning wrestling and they came up with this wrestling choreography to make sure everyone would be safe in the scene. That just blew my mind. I don't know why. Yeah, what a crazy job to get. I know what you do today. I wrestled James Spader. Yeah, most of the morning. I didn't have any lines, but that was my job.
Well, I have a question for you. Yes. What happened to Gabe? What do you mean? I mean Gabe walked in with Dwight. Oh, he said, yay! While they were wrestling, what did we never see him again? Oh my gosh, you're so right. I didn't even notice that. Well, here is what I got obsessed with in this scene. And I'm glad I did, because it really pays off. When Robert is done wrestling, he offers Dwight an Oreo
from a platter of Oreos because he says they haven't really improved on the Oreo half-day. I did a deep dive on Oreos. I love that he brought him out on a platter and I love that you are doing a deep dive. I'm going to sit back. I can't wait to hear this. Well, first of all, you know, there's the Oreo and there's the Hydrox cookie. They're both sandwich cookies that have like chocolate with a cream filling, right?
Which one do you think came from? I've never heard of the Hydrox cookie. I don't know what you're saying about that. I don't know what you're saying. You've never heard of a Hydrox cookie? It sounds like something you like clean like you're sink with. Put in the Hydrox cookie. Cassie, have you heard of the Hydrox cookie?
Make sure you put in a Hydrox cookie in your dishwasher once. Cassie has not heard of the Hydrox cookie. Make sure you put in a Hydrox Cookie in your dishwasher once. Cassie has not heard of the Hydrox Cookie. Oh my gosh. Sam has. All right, growing up, the Hydrox Cookie was always kind of like, what? Like it was like the knockoff Oreo, right? Sam is nodding. Yes. I'm going to blow your mind, Sam.
The Hydrox came first. Oreo is a ripoff of the hydrox. Oh, but it ended up just surpassing the hydrox and popularity such that Cassie and Angela have not even heard of it. Why was it, what did Oreo do differently? I don't know, but it tastes better, right? The Oreo tastes better than the hydrox. Well, I don't know what first it tastes better, right? The Oreo tastes better than the Hydrox.
Well, I don't know what first error was naming it Hydrox. The Hydrox is a terrible name. It does sound like a cleaning solution. All right, but Oreos were created in 1912, which was about three years after the Hydrox, which was invented in 1908. Oreos were invented in New York City, and they are so popular that the street
in which the first Nabisco factory is located where the Oreo was first manufactured is actually called Oreo Way. It's in Chelsea, New York. This blew my mind. It takes two hours to make one Oreo cookie. That's how long it takes to make the whole thing. Today, they produce 40 billion Oreo cookies per year, and if you stacked them all together, they would circle the Earth five times. Wow.
Every year. Wow. Also in 2011, the Oreo cookie received the Guinness World Record for the world's biggest selling cookie with sales in excess of 500 billion since its debut. The Oreo cookie, while it takes two hours to bake, it only contains 11 ingredients. And Oreo cookies are kosher, and they're very popular with vegans because they contain no animal products. However, in their frequently asked questions, they do want you to know there is a risk of cross contamination because they are made in a facility that does make things with milk, although there is no milk in the Oreo. But here's the other crazy thing.
No one knows the origin of the name Oreo. We don't know why it's called an Oreo. Doesn't stand for anything. There's a lot of speculation that maybe it has like roots in some Latin word, but yeah. I was very excited when I did this deep dive in it dinner. I announced it to my whole family. What they think.
They were fascinated by it. My son has heard of the Hydrox, by the way. And he knew that the Hydrox came by the way, and he knew that the Hydrox came first. No, he knew. What? I was shocked that the Hydrox came first. I don't know, but he was like, Mom, everyone knows that. Everyone knows that. I did not know that. I know. So anyway, my family was like, where did the name come from? That was their big question. I was like, no one knows. Nobody knows. Hmm.
That, my friends, is your Oreo cookie deep-dive. It's making me want an Oreo. Well, I was doing this deep-dive to Oreos. And by the way, the gluten-free Oreo is delicious as well. My favorite Oreo is the yellow one, the lemon cream. No, isn't there one that's- The vanilla one? Yeah.
Yeah, it's very good. I like to put it in the fridge and eat it cold. You like a cold vanilla Oreo. Fascinating. I'm bringing on sex to your back. What? Well, Robert is really trying to do the thing he set out to do, the Peter principle.
He's trying to get Dwight to stay right in the position he's in. He's like, you don't want to live in Florida. And you know what? He said, I want to give you something. He says that he wants to give Dwight his grandfather's medal, that his grandfather was awarded for acts of courage and excellence. But he pulls it out of a drawer that I'm sorry. It looks like that catch-all drawer in your kitchen. Sure does.
It's got everything in it. And this special metal apparently. Yeah, and Dwight's like, you know what? I don't need a trinket from a flea market, you know? Yeah. I think Robert has a lot of these metals. I think this is his go-to drawer. Well, this is the thing.
So the fan catch from Scott P and Tennessee said, did you notice that the metal that Robert gives Dwight also appears framed at Gabe's desk? We talked about this. Yes. When you see Gabe's desk throughout this episode, you can see it plain as day. Thor M from Washington, DC also spotted this and added that he feels like this really shows the difference between Gabe and Dwight, that Gabe cherished this object and needed to display it, you know, maybe to impress Robert or maybe to impress other people. Stephanie and the lobby, I mean, it's right there
in his squirrel desk area. Thor also said, I actually have that medal. I was awarded it twice. Oh, Thor said humble brag, but actually have that medal. I was awarded it twice. Oh, Thor said humble brag, but the award that Robert is attempting to give Dwight is an army achievement medal. And this adds another level of irony to the show that I love as a veteran, because an AAM would never be given for bravery or valor, but it is more like an exemplary service medal, like as a commemoration of your time in a military unit.
And they are given as a going away medal, as like a summary of all your achievements at your unit before you move on to the next chapter. So he thought it was very interesting that Robert is handing out these sort of going away metal. Take this metal and now go away. Go away. Exactly. And in fact, he says to Dwight, I'll think of you if something comes up, now get the hell out of my condo. Yes. But you know what? Dwight likes it when he talks straight to him. Yeah. When he says, I'm not giving you this job,
but if something comes up that you're right for, I'll tell you. Right. So it's like, I accept that. That's enough for him. Yeah. Back at the bar, we're in the final round of trivia. We are, and I have a fun little background catch. During the scene, you can see out the windows, and it looks like night. Is Steve there in a beard and eyebrows? No, you never see him again.
But that was faking night. Oh, it was really day. Steve Healy said that we had to do day for night shooting. And day for night shooting is when they have to cover the windows with like big black scrims. But then they also have to put enough light outside the window that it looks like nighttime. They did a really good job. I became slightly obsessed with looking out the windows and being like, that's not really night. You had so much to look at in the background in this episode.
I really do. Very busy. I was. Well, in this final round, things are getting heated. The trivia host reads this question, the standard American analog scale has a maximum capacity of what weight? Kevin rings the bell, 300 pounds.
He knows the answer. No, the answer. Einstein's get it. Final question. For all the cine files out there, put on your memory burrays, the final question is a doozy. It's about a French film. Oscar thinks he has this in the bag. He's very confident with his answer. But no, it's incorrect. And who has the right answer, but Kevin? And the Einstein's win. The Einstein's win because Kevin answered the last two questions correctly.
他知道答案。不，是这个答案。爱因斯坦队答对了。最后一题。对于所有的影迷朋友们，转动你们的记忆大脑，最后一题可是一个难题。这是一部法国电影。奥斯卡以为这题他稳拿了。他对自己的答案非常自信。但并没有，这回答是错的。谁答对了呢，不就是凯文吗？于是爱因斯坦队赢了。爱因斯坦队赢了，因为凯文最后两道题都答对了。
Kevin, the person that Andy forced off the A team in the very beginning. Yes. Kevin has a great talking head where he says, you know, maybe tonight was a fluke, but fluke is the most common fish in the sea. It's the fish you're most likely to catch when you go fishing. There was a Kevin all talking head. It's in deleted scenes and he talks about his level of education. Here's what he said. When I dropped out of school to watch more sports, a lot of people thought I was nuts. Well, who's laughing now?
凯文，就是安迪在一开始强行逼出A队的那个。是的。凯文有一段精彩的单人访谈，他说，你知道的，也许今晚只是走运，但比目鱼（fluke，与走运谐音）是海里最常见的鱼。当你去钓鱼时，最容易钓到的就是它。还有一段凯文的单人访谈被删掉了。他在里面谈到了自己的受教育程度。他是这么说的：当我辍学去看更多体育比赛时，很多人觉得我疯了。好吧，现在谁在笑呢？
What's funny is that Kevin never answered a sports question. I know, I know. But we found out he dropped out of school. And then there's a deleted Oscar talking head where he sort of sums up the day. It's pretty funny, I'm gonna read it to you. It gets better kids. It gets so much better that one day your stupid co-workers will be excited to show up at your gay bar and ruin your trivia night Oh, boy. I don't think I want to be in that accounting clump tomorrow Hey, Angela had nothing to do with it. That's right. But it would be kind of icy between Kevin and Oscar.
有趣的是，凯文从来没有回答过任何体育问题。我知道，我知道。但我们发现他辍学了。然后还有一段被删掉的奥斯卡的单人访谈，他在那里算是总结了这一天。挺搞笑的，我读给你们听听。情况会好起来的，孩子们。情况会好转到有一天，你那愚蠢的同事们会兴高采烈地出现在你的同性恋酒吧里，毁了你的知识问答之夜。噢，天哪。我明天可不想卷入那群会计中间了。嘿，安吉拉这事可跟他没关系。没错。但凯文和奥斯卡之间可能会有点冷场。
So the tag for this episode is another trivia night. The Einstein's have made it to the state championships. The state championships in all of Pennsylvania. That's insane. The host of this trivia night is played by comedian Dan Levy. He is hilarious, by the way. And here's a crazy odd coincidence. Just one of those things how life comes back around. Dan was my husband's roommate when they
所以这一集的彩蛋是又一个知识问答之夜。爱因斯坦队已经打入了州锦标赛。整个宾夕法尼亚州的州锦标赛。这太疯狂了。这个知识问答之夜的主持人由喜剧演员丹·利维饰演。顺便说一句，他太搞笑了。这里有一个疯狂的巧合。这就是生活兜兜转转的奇妙之处。丹在我丈夫20多岁的时候
were in their 20s. No way. Yeah. Oh my god. They were roommates. They had met in an acting class. They're still friends. He is hilarious. And he tours with John Mulaney. He's so funny. I'm going to put a little swipe up to Dan because he's fantastic. Well, I remember him from his role in the TV show Enlightened. He is awesome. Oh, yeah. Well, guys, that is trivia. I want to give a big thank you to Steve Burgess and Steve Healy for all your tidbits.
是他的室友。不会吧。是的。哦，天哪。他们曾是室友。他们是在一个表演班上认识的。他们现在还是朋友。他太搞笑了。他跟约翰·木兰尼一起巡演。他太有趣了。我要为丹点个赞，因为他太棒了。嗯，我记得他在电视剧《醍醐灌顶》里的角色。他太棒了。哦，是的。好了，各位，这就是知识问答。我要对史蒂夫·伯吉斯和史蒂夫·希利为我们提供所有的花絮表示深切的感谢。
You know, Angela Steve Healy was so sweet. I have to read you what he said at the end of our email chain. Okay. Talking about trivia. He just said thank you to both of us and he said, anytime I think back on the office, it's a deep wave of memories. Some of them just of the late nights and stress and weird food, but it's also so fun to remember. And more than anything, I am grateful I was part of such a project that people love so
你知道吗，安吉拉，史蒂夫·希利太贴心了。我必须读一下他在我们的电子邮件结尾时说的话。好的。谈到知识问答。他只是对我们俩表示感谢，他说，每当我回想起《办公室》，就会涌起一股深刻的记忆浪潮。其中有些只是关于熬夜、压力和奇怪的食物，但回想起来也很有趣。最重要的是，我很感激自己能参与这样一个深受大家喜爱的项目
much. I think that sums it up. Yeah, that's how I feel too. Yeah. And a special thank you to my friend Brian Gattis for sharing with us what it was like being on set shooting those bar scenes. Brian has been in a ton of things and you can check him out on Instagram at Built by Gattis.
那么多。我想这就做个总结吧。是的，我也是这种感觉。是的。特别感谢我的朋友布赖恩·加蒂斯与我们分享在片场拍摄那些酒吧场景的感受。布赖恩参演过大量作品，你可以在Instagram上关注他，账号是Built by Gattis。
He does his own ceramics, Jenna. Really? I know. I might be in the market for some ceramics. I love handmade things. You really do. Well, guys, thanks so much for listening. We have a two week end of summer break, and then we will be back with a new episode.
他自己做陶艺，珍娜。真的吗？我知道。我可能正想买点陶艺品呢。我喜欢手工制作的东西。你确实喜欢。好了，各位，非常感谢大家的收听。我们将进行为期两周的夏末休息，然后带着新的一集回归。
Take care, you guys. See you then! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbleco.
保重，各位。到时候见！感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwool、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·吉尔金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴布科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to stiturapremium.com. For a free one-month trial of stiturapremium, use code office. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里夫·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问stiturapremium.com。如需免费试用一个月stiturapremium，请使用优惠码office。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。